[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
samedi dernier une centaine d'enfants de
l'agglomération de 50 ans en Yvelines et
de Chanteloup-les-Vignes ont reçu leur
propre instruments de musique sur la
scène nationale du théâtre de Sky c'est
dans le cadre du projet demos dispositif
d'éducation musicale et orchestrale à
vocation sociale mis en place par la
Philharmonie de Paris
c'est à la fois une fierté mais aussi
une joie de voir le bonheur de ses
enfants qui vont pouvoir maintenant
rentrer dans l'apprentissage de la
musique en orchestre
parce que je sais que je continuerai à
faire du violoncelle ou
autre chanson donc bah ça me rend
heureuse alors moi je suis pressée parce
que en fait quand on m'a dit qu'on avait
reçu les instruments enfin ça m'a fait
un choc et c'était il va bien parce que
je me sentais déjà musicienne
alors ça va être cool instrument avant
accorde ou cuivre les enfants vont
suivre pendant trois ans des ateliers
hebdomadaires le tout encadré par deux
musiciens professionnels et un référent
de la structure sociale partenaire on
lutte aussi contre tous les a priori qui
consisteraient à penser que la musique
classique serait réservée une élite et
et vraiment la spécificité de Demos
c'est d'apporter la musique classique
dans les quartiers populaires et
vraiment au sein de ces quartiers dans
les structures sociales 50% des enfants
choisissent de poursuivre la musique
donc on met en place des partenariats
avec les écoles de musique locale pour
créer des passerelles et pour que les
enfants puissent intégrer les
apprentissages de ces respiratoires à
l'issue des Mosses nouveautés cette
année l'agglomération de 50 ans en
Yvelines devient opérateur du dispositif
des mousses un grand concert public
viendra clôturer la saison et les
enfants ont également l'opportunité de
monter sur la grande scène de la
Philharmonie de Paris de quoi les
motiver la clé de la réussite pratique à
un peu tous les jours